you know at least in the Spanish
Inquisition you had a chance to respond
to your interrogator so there's
something pathological about this on the
one hand they're so arrogant as to think
that they should decide what the BBC and
other news media are allowed to cover
and what people should be exposed to and
then they're so insecure and so small
that they refuse to stand for public
debate with me
this is how you get to totalitarianism
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters of
me monster martial at The Spectator
today I had the pleasure of being joined
by Michael schellenberger who as well as
writing the Books San Francisco uh
apocalypse never as a history as an
environmentalist uh was also ran as a
Californian gubernatorial candidate
um and actually has the dubious honor of
being my first return guest to Marshall
matters but since our lot we last spoke
which I think was in October November
last year you've had incredible uh run
and you're you're sort of life and
career has taken another kind of swing
and as well as building up publicly on
your newsletter you're also one of the
Twitter files journalists along with
Matt Tybee very wisely Fang Dave Swagg
others David I've had the pleasure of
speaking with him as well and
um only last I think week or two weeks
ago you exposed what has been called for
the last three is a conspiracy theory
about patients zero being at the Wuhan
Institute for virology
and it's so there's there's lots to
discuss but Michael thank you so much
for coming to speak with me today
Winston's pleasure thank you
um so actually the reason you're in
London is you're doing this event with
your co- Twitter files journalist Matt
Tybee as well as Rusty Rockets himself
Russell Brand at Central Hall
Westminster exposing the uh censorship
industrial complex for people who have
no idea what the censorship industrial
complex is how would you describe it
well to answer that question you really
have to go back to the beginning of the
Twitter files so we were invited in I
mean really it was as you mentioned
mataibi Barry Weiss were invited by Elon
Musk
um and his associates into Twitter to
figure out what was going on because we
knew that there was pretty significant
censorship of disfavored voices mostly
conservative voices but other voices too
for several years and and Elon was
committed to some transparency on as to
what was happening so we were given a
pretty broad access to emails and
internal messages through Slack
and at first it was sort of a picture
and we published a series of things
about there was just a lot of what you
would call woke culture 99 of political
donations from Twitter Executives had
gone to Democrats
and so they were censoring things like
you know a one user Megan Murphy wrote
in response to a trans debate she wrote
you know but men aren't women though and
she was de-platformed for tweeting that
Graham Lincoln the British comedian who
I've also had on the show had exactly
the same tweet men aren't women though
and were suspended from Twitter yeah so
that was so that was clearly a cultural
strong cultural and political bias but
then we started seeing something else
that was very strange which was requests
from the FBI to de-platform people and
people from the Department of Homeland
Security the DHS which was the
coordinating body created after 9 11 in
the United States
and that was very chilling to start to
see basically law enforcement and
intelligence agencies demand that people
be censored effectively by Twitter
Executives how is that working is they
were sending emails to uh
those at Twitter demanding specifically
things take that and there was payment
there was money involved right
well right I mean this is all of this is
of course hugely contentious and in fact
your uh conversation with the Telegraph
reporter because what was happening here
in Britain was very similar I mean we
were reading these stories that were
coming out of the telegraph that had
been coming out of the telegraph the
last several weeks so the Defenders of
this practice say look this is just you
know government officials flagging
violations of Twitter's terms of service
what could possibly be wrong with that
well you know there's a lot wrong with
it
um there was a bit you know basically
the government officials both in the UK
and in the United States who were who
were requesting censorship of users
we're getting Priority Access so it
wasn't sort of an equal opportunity
thing they were right there so you see
the the Twitter is creating a bias
towards government demands for
censorship
the United States we have even stricter
protections of speech than you do in
Britain though they're very strong here
too but for the United States it you
can't the government cannot interfere in
the rights of people to express
themselves except for in a very limited
number of cases basically around
incitement to violence and fraud
and so even having the government
requesting censorship by Twitter
Executives is in my view and the view of
many legal Scholars a violation of the
First Amendment of the Constitution
so then um then the money this was I was
the first to report on this is that we
then started to see in 2020 Twitter
started to accept payments from the
federal government for its efforts this
was legally Justified as the expense of
Twitter Executives having to engage in
these activities and there's a law that
allows for compensation if you're
helping on a federal investigation or a
law enforcement investigation the social
media Executives can be compensated for
it but it's a clear conflict of interest
you're paying people to engage in
censorship and so there was a lot of
debate about that and whether it was
justified
but to make a long story short it was
widespread it was a very intensive and
coordinated activity by multiple
government agencies in the United States
in the UK
requesting censorship on Myriad issues
we mentioned transgenderism climate
change covid was a huge one I mean maybe
the most egregious is where White House
officials demanding that Facebook censor
people for sharing true stories about
vaccine side effects this is
particularly offensive it should be
particularly offensive to progressives
in the United States because there have
been a huge effort to require
pharmaceutical companies to name the
side effects of their drugs in their
television ads and here people were
describing the side effects of this drug
um to them on themselves and you had the
government demanding that it'd be
censored it was the demand was made that
it'd be censored not because it was
misinformation not because it was
disinformation but because it was true
information that might lead to vaccine
hesitancy to a reluctance on the part of
people to get vaccines so we're we're
now we're in 1984 or well territory so
that's sort of Mal information Mal
information true information that's
inconvenient exactly that results in
that make results in behaviors that we
don't like well at that point I mean you
could justify censorship of anything and
so you're dealing with I mean involve
the philosophers here I mean because any
idea could lead to a bad outcome sure
absolutely and we know that you know
people make up all sorts of reasons for
different kinds of behaviors and people
defend behaviors retroactively occurring
for different reasons than they had at
the time I mean you know there's a whole
long tradition the philosophy of
language that looks at how people reason
and so you basically giving a very broad
justification for censorship and it just
as you might imagine it just spiraled
out of control and you saw abuses of
power
right away and I hasten to add we
struggle ourselves to find the right
language to describe the kinds of things
that we were seeing
on the one hand it's censorship and in
some ways that's the easiest to
understand but there was also propaganda
and disinformation being spread by
government officials one of the twists
what's the difference between propaganda
and disinformation well
that's a also a very good question and
it's not clear that there's a very good
answer to it propaganda on the one hand
is just government public relations at
the simplest level disinformation is
what we call propaganda by other
governments that we don't like but even
that word got what we saw was
government contractors in the United
States and government former government
officials including former CIA officials
saying well we're now we were concerned
about Russian disinformation in the 2016
elections already by 2018 you saw the
same people saying well it turns out
that actually most of the disinformation
is coming from ordinary Americans so
suddenly we have a turning inward of a
word that by the way had been used in
context of warfare so one of the most
famous examples of of disinformation
disinformation that those of us in the
west support was the use of the ghost
Army in World War II so that it we made
it look like we were going to invade or
that the Americans were going to help
the Brits to uh invade Europe and fight
the Nazis across the the channel instead
of course we did it through Normandy but
they created this fake ghost Army that
was disinformation or what we might call
psyops psychological operations
so disinformation which was just used to
describe Russian efforts to sway the
2016 elections very quickly then became
turned Inward and that's one of the
themes of this work is that we saw
people that had been involved in the war
on terrorism after 9 11.
I had a huge amount of success reducing
and fighting terrorism around the world
suddenly you have this huge apparatus
for fighting terrorists that had nowhere
to go and it's it turned inward after
2016. partly in reaction to brexit
partly in reaction to the election of
trump
and so this is a this was a very
disturbing Trend and so we start to see
the intelligence and security agencies
of the United States officially and
unofficially get involved in suppressing
mostly populist mostly conservative
voices but also some left-wing anti-war
voices dissident covid dissidents and
one of the things I wrote about was the
effort to basically
run a disinformation campaign around the
hunter Biden laptop which surfaces in
October 14 2020 a New York Post article
what we saw were former government
officials including many former
directors of the CIA we saw a former FBI
officials including work ones working at
Twitter the Jim Baker Jim Baker the
former the former Chief counsel for the
FBI took a deputy Council role at
Twitter
internally making the case that the
hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation which by the way is a
crazy conspiracy theory when you
consider here they had Russia they had
100 binds laptop they had the subpoena
from the FBI confiscating the hunter
Biden laptop in December 2019 and when
was Jim Baker the CIA Jim Baker leaves
Jim Baker arrives at Twitter in the
summer of 2020. so he would have known
about the hunter Biden
well we don't we don't know we don't
know ostensibly there is
compartmentalization of information you
know need to know
but I mean he was I mean general counsel
of the FBI is arguably as powerful as
the Director they need to be involved in
multiple FBI operations
to make sure that they're legal that's
the role of the one of the roles of the
general accounts of the FBI is to make
sure that the FBI is not breaking the
laws that are supposed to constrain them
so the FBI confiscates the hunter buying
laptop in December 2019 they give the
computer store repair owner who had the
laptop and it gave it they gave him a
subpoena which is almost like in that
case it's almost like a receipt that we
have it we have the receipt signed by
Hunter Biden dropping the computer off
the New York Post publishes both of
those in their coverage and then you get
this cockamamie conspiracy theory
suggesting that somehow the Russians had
hacks Hunter Biden's computers and then
put them on a computer I mean the more
straightforward stories that Hunter
Biden at the time well-known alcoholic
and addict dropped the computer laptops
in his bathtub or in a pool
so you have basically former government
officials
ostensibly former government officials
and by the way one of the things that
you hear when you interview people in
the intelligence communities they say
nobody ever leaves the intelligence
Community well that's interesting that's
interesting because I just want to talk
about the case of Jim Baker for one
second because it would be easy for uh
people looking uh for examples of
collusion to just be like oh look
there's a revolving door between
government and big Tech take Jim Baker
he was there back and forth but it's
also possible is it not that he could
have just had that job
you know ended that and gone in for a
different industry is it what evidence
do we have there's a really revolving
door or or that there's really collusion
there in in the sense that the same
people are going back and forth well in
the Twitter files I did on on the hunter
buying laptop so if people want to look
at look at it they can just Google you
know shellenberger 100 buying laptop so
yeah you did that was part seven of the
Twitter cards and you did part four
which was uh January 7th yes and then
part seven which was FBI in the
underbidden laptop yeah yeah and we can
come back to the the decision to
de-platform Trump because obviously it's
a massive moment in the history of
social media but in the case of the
underlying laptop I mean you I mean so
first of all Jim Baker had been in and
out of the FBI so that revolving door
had already occurred he'd gone in and
come out went back out
came to Twitter and what was so striking
is that the team that was assigned the
task of deciding whether or not the New
York Post article about the hunterbind
laptop violated Twitter's terms of
service they came back and were very
clear that it did not violate their
terms of service therefore there should
be no censorship or restrictions on that
tweet or on that account
the case then was made internally in
Twitter to censor it anyway and it was
made by Jim Baker he made it most
forcefully he made it in multiple
instances both in
internal Communications in a Google doc
where they were
discussing and shaping a kind of
response to it he was very strenuous by
far the most strenuous person making the
case that it was Russian disinformation
on the basis of absolutely nothing on
the basis of total speculation of just
kind of word salad basically to censor
it and he ultimately won out and you
know I always you know the way that
bad things happen often is by telephone
so that there's no record of them so the
fact that we have such extensive written
suggestors I have to assume I think it's
fair to assume there was a lot of phone
calls going on as well but um it was
after Jim Baker's intervention that that
Twitter Executives did decide to censor
the New York Post article
I also this comes back to this earlier
point I wanted to make which is that to
understand what's going on here it's Not
Mere censorship it's also always
disinformation and censorship or what
the people involved in this call an
influence operation or an information
operation so the censorship of the
hunter Biden laptop tweets by the New
York Post were so significant in my view
not simply because it restricted access
to that content because but because of
what it communicated it was saying that
Twitter felt that this was
disinformation and so for me at the time
I was a Biden voter a Biden supporter or
I thought Trump was chaotic and and was
like many Democrats at the time
felt it needed to go I looked at the
hunter buying laptop and I also thought
that it seemed like it was two two or
three weeks before the elections
it was you know Rudy Giuliani was
involved in it it was New York Post
rather than the New York Times uh you
know like many uh liberals at the time I
had a very snobby view of the New York
Post
and so when the when Twitter and
Facebook said that they were censoring
the content for me that was another
black mark and another reason to think
that it was not true or that it was not
accurate so the censorship itself is
part of the influence operation even
though the native one points out people
that defend the decision they say well
Twitter lifted the censorship
um after a few days and that's true but
I think the stigma remained on the
content so it led it gave people reason
like me uh gave people a reason to
believe that it was in fact Russian
disinformation when it wasn't it was
actually exactly what it appeared to be
there's another aspect of it which which
is sort of typical about this and I
think important to understanding how a
lot of this operates is the Russian
disinformation aspect itself and this is
something that taibi I believe in the
truth Falls explains the Hamilton 68
Group which was then the foundation of
Jacob Siegel's phenomenal piece uh
exposing the censorship more broadly and
and the the Russia disinformation is in
fact a hoax and that's that's the kind
of thing that I think is still not quite
understood I wonder I wonder what your
your
opinion on that was on on the rush or
maybe how would someone who doesn't
understand that the Russia hoax how
could you explain it to them well the
easiest way is you go back I mean you
look at 2016 there were efforts by
people with ties to the Russian
government to do basically two things
run ads on Facebook and also have fake
accounts or what are sometimes called
bot accounts to try to influence the
election
everybody who's looked at this every
independent scholar who's looked at this
say they cannot find any effect of
either the advertising or the fake
accounts they were just drowned out by
so much other Communications on those
couldn't find the effects of it but I I
thought that that we had agreed that
there probably were Russian Bots yes but
that there were not many of them exactly
right but then the Hamilton 68 group
what's important about that is is that
that was a government-backed group
specifically designed to spread the
disinformation that there was a that
there was Russian disinformation that's
right right that's right so so but just
to sort of back up you have a after 2016
you have this allegation that
Trump won with the help of the Russians
there was never any evidence to show
that the that any Russian involvement
had any impact on any voters you know do
you give a sense of it most Republicans
uh got their news from Fox News not from
Facebook but even the communications
that we could tie to Russia just were
trivial I mean it's just a just in a
wash of information online so but it was
it was grossly exaggerated to start with
then you get to 2018 and one of the most
important figures in the censorship
industrial complex named Renee diresta a
former CIA fellow at least allegedly
former then at Stanford and also at a
political organization that did
campaigns for Democrats does senate
intelligence testimony
um testifying to some and grossly
exaggerates the effect the Russians
and then you get to this thing called
Hamilton 68 which is part of a think
tank called The Alliance for securing
democracy
and what Tai my colleague mataibi
discovers is that what they were doing
was
calling genuine users Russian Bots
as a way to discredit them and to get
them censored on Twitter or more
importantly I would argue it was a way
to generate a lot of news media coverage
I mean dozens maybe hundreds of news
articles were written claiming that
Russian Bots were active on Twitter and
really trying to get people to see
Trump's supporters populists populist
right type users trying to get them to
see them as Russian Bots this is a
really important aspect I hope we can
come back to this is the the
Legacy Media is complicit complicity in
the complex of it all because it's and
and also now saying there's no even
though this stuff has been exposed
not only are they ignoring their
participation in it uh but they're
they're well there's no attempt to
correct the record uh they'll ignore the
story completely as with the Twitter
files huge story Legacy Media pretty
much ignored it there's very there was
very little
reporting of it well worse than that
they participate in it I mean if you I
mean really the dark view of it is that
they were participating in the
disinformation and to give you a sense
of it knowingly you think well that's
interesting because that gets into
questions of intention which are hard to
read but I mean I the the moment that
the the scariest moment for me in the
Twitter files was stumbling across an
aspen Institute Workshop that they
called a tabletop exercise
which involved all of the major news
media New York Times CNN Washington Post
NPR Daily Beast wired
participating alongside the so-called
trust and safety professionals that's
what we call sent the main sensors at
Facebook and Twitter in an aspen
Workshop
in the summer of 2020
to basically coordinate how they are
going to cover and not cover
potential Hunter Biden scandal around
barisma the natural gas company that he
worked for and the Scandal that by the
way is the on the laptop it there's an
email which says thank you and this is
too Hunter Biden from I think the one of
the advisors on the barisma board saying
thank you for the opportunity to meet
your father right that the the 10 for
the big eyes the China that's a China
right thing and but then Biden has
denied ever meeting so we don't actually
know that Biden met anyone on the
barisma board but that's the there's the
one email which says thanks the
opportunity to meet your father sorry
yeah well and I mean look I mean the the
100 buying laptop what it shows in a
nutshell is his son and uh Hunter Biden
and and and the president's brother just
engaging in influence peddling whilst
Biden was VP well Biden was vice
president and now we're in the midst of
a huge new Scandal the United States
alleging uh direct criminal bribery
involving the president and there's a
huge conflict between the Congress and
the FBI to try to get some of the
documents and The Whistleblower and the
witness to it but basically yeah you see
these two family members the Son and the
brother selling access to the father
with some idea that that they will be
able to influence his decision making I
mean that's why people would pay for the
influence
um and disturbing stuff I mean it's not
I think that the people that sort of
wave it away they kind of go well that's
how it works in Washington but it's not
how we should want it to work in
Washington and even if it were entirely
legal it may it probably shouldn't be or
at least it should be something that
voters should know about rather than you
shouldn't censor the story let them know
about it that's yeah that's the or
spread propaganda about it misleading
people about it so yeah but this um the
participation of the news media in some
ways it's the main event in the sense
that the the decisions by Twitter and
Facebook are certainly important but
it's you've got this when you have the
entire mainstream news media telling you
that the hunter buying laptop is not
what it appears to be it's it's you have
to be I mean it basically allowed for
swing voters the people that would
determine the election yeah to dismiss
this very important uh piece of
information
and but what was creepy about it was
that here they were it was orchestrated
so you saw all of these news media with
the social media Representatives
engaged in these this Zoom conference
calls where they were basically planning
how they were going to not cover or
cover in a manipulative way this big
story and this this has to do with
What's called the Pentagon papers
principle The Pentagon Papers Of course
is the very uh famous decision by Daniel
Ellsberg who just passed away to uh when
he was a defense department analyst to
steal I think it was in 1969
a set of documents from the Pentagon
showing that the United States was
losing the war in Vietnam it was
considered a very courageous decision by
The Washington Post the New York Times
to publish these stolen documents it was
the subject of a Steven Spielberg movie
called the post about the Washington
Post decision to do this this was
considered a Triumph for the First
Amendment these documents had been
stolen
um Daniel Ellsberg risked prison to
steal these documents in order to get
out this very important truth that the
US was losing not winning the war in
Vietnam what you saw in that Hunter
Biden Workshop in the summer of 2020 was
an effort to undermine this very
fundamental journalistic principle that
you should publish those documents even
if they were stolen the journalists
should be protected under the First
Amendment to publish those documents
even if they had been acquired illegally
by a source
so what we saw was in that workshop and
then also in a prior white paper by a
Stanford Think Tank an attack on the
Pentagon papers principle and the attack
was basically the following it was you
must not emphasize the content of those
documents you should instead emphasize
how they were acquired so if some
negative information were to come out
about Hunter Biden before the election
you must emphasize that they were almost
certainly the result of a Russian Hack
and leak operation as opposed to maybe
Hunter Biden just dropped his laptops in
his bathtub and and then took them to
the computer store wow that's another
level I mean in in this country we had
uh recently Isabel oakshaw who was hired
as the Ghost Rider for the health
secretary during the pandemic man Matt
Hancock and she published or handed over
the his WhatsApp messages
which included him saying he wanted to
scare the pants off the British public
as a way of controlling them to get
through the pandemic and the response
that she got was that instead of
the other journalists being like wow
look at what the government were doing
they went for her and the ethics of of
her leak right which is it's the thought
that the priority is to hold the
government to account first and foremost
okay sure there's problems with the
ethics of you could there's an
interesting conversation to have but
it's not the first conversation you have
you actually discuss
what that Bloody government were doing
well it's it's I'm your right to make
that comparison it's I mean I'm shocked
by how when I see these things happen
here in the UK we follow it pretty
closely and it's identical basically to
what's going on so what you what you're
seeing are basically state propagandists
within the government in the United
States and in the UK
trying to change shift the focus for
journalists and that's always happened
that's what state propaganda's that's
what their job is
um but what's shocking about it is to
see the way the journalists are
participating with the state as opposed
to having a much more skeptical or even
antagonistic role in this in the
Spielberg movie about the pending on
papers there's this sort of defining
moment where Catherine Graham the
publisher of the Washington Post
has an argument with the defense
secretary
um Robert McNamara and their friends you
know they have dinner parties together
it's very Clubby and he gets very angry
at her and threatens her and she stands
up to him I mean that's sort of the
that's sort of what it means to be an
independent journalist well here we we
see
the government behaving thuggishly with
the journalists and the journalists sort
of going along with it and I think it
has to be understood as well as part of
the elite Panic after 2016. Trump
derangement syndrome is a very real
thing in Washington and among you know
not just liberals in general but really
Elites who I think thought that Trump
and brexit combined represented a threat
to the liberal world order so is is that
the core of this huge phenomenon you
think it's Trump derangement system
that's that's the thing at the very
Roots that's motivating that's that's
the the energy let's say behind the
censorship industrial complex I think so
I think that there was it was preceded
by what Martin Gurley calls the Revolt
of the public Unleashed by the internet
in general and by social media in
particular so I mean suddenly I mean you
see this moment in 2016 where Hillary
Clinton refers to Trump supporters as
the people you could put in a basket of
deplorables the unwashed you know the
math the rabble there's some sense in
which Twitter and Facebook are allowing
Ordinary People to speak ugh horrible
right these you know these these common
people with their typos and their poor
language and their crude ways
and so there was a kind of disgust at
the ability of the masses to speak in
the ways that they were able to with the
rise of social media and then and then
of course attributing Trump's rise and
attributing brexit same thing uh to the
to social media which you know
ironically or not ironically most
Scholars do not attribute uh I don't
actually know about brexit um but they
do not attribute Trump's Victory to
social media it is something a lot of
people would say he took advantage of
Twitter and certainly gave him a way to
do that but ultimately uh I think most
political scientists think that Trump
wins by uh really some powerful debate
performances embracing a more
Nationalist and populist message and so
I think you have a deliberate or or
accidental misattribution of Trump's
success to social media the reason it
might be deliberate is because they
wanted to gain control over these
Technologies and they basically did
achieve that after 2016 mean you saw
incredible you know it's one thing to
try to control all the major news media
but you're talking about like 12
powerful news organizations or two or
three if you just look at the New York
Times Washington Post
but when you then can only when you only
have really two Facebook and Twitter to
really as a choke hold on the entire
discourse and also as a means of of
spreading propaganda or disinformation
uh it's a whole new ball game there was
a lot of talk in the 2016 election that
Facebook was how yeah he won do you do
you think that um how did you get the
information earlier you said this
earlier in the conversation about the
Facebook uh having being in contact with
with government because you Twitter was
exposed but how how have you got that
about Facebook how do you know what's
going on there
so Facebook yeah well that's a great
question I'm glad you asked so the
Twitter files was not the only uh Source
way to understand what was going on
inside the social media companies the
other thing that was going on is that
the Attorneys General the top attorneys
for the states of Louisiana and Missouri
sued the federal government for
censorship by federal government
employees by putting pressure on
Facebook and Twitter
and so they achieved a bunch of
Discovery their right to get emails and
whatnot so we have this we have these
emails from the White House to Facebook
demanding more censorship and we also
have the same people are the same people
are doing the same making the same
demands on Twitter very aggressive
government officials Rob Flaherty Andy
slavitt are the other two officials
they're a little bit like the Matt
Hancock here I think uh calling berating
Facebook and Twitter Executives that
they're not censoring enough
and in that lawsuit we start to see uh
Facebook bending we've seen those files
bending to the will of the White House
you have to remember after 2016
elections when Democrats start saying
that Facebook is the social media is to
blame for Trump's victory
Mark Zuckerberg the creator of Facebook
just thought that was ridiculous and he
said so
it was absurd to him that Facebook could
have had that role but you saw the
pressure was so intense on Zuckerberg
between 2016 and 2020. by 2020 many
senior Executives had come from not just
American intelligence and security
agencies but also from British ones
and there's always a justification for
it because these are people that were
good at doing investigations these are
people that are are they understand
what's going on in places like Myanmar
where Facebook had been abused to
to contribute to attacks on the rohingya
so there's always some sort of
justification for it but you start to
see basically the capturing of Facebook
and Twitter by us and UK intelligence
Services ostensibly retired officials
but again if you believe what people in
the intelligence Services tell you
nobody ever really retires yeah I I'm
gonna ask a question which might be a
bit too much mental gymnastics but I I
but I wondered whether you think
when we mentioned right at the beginning
of this conversation 9 11. 911 the
Patriot Act getting leading to Stellar
Wind that if you take that sort of
trajectory is linked once we're starting
to by wanting to protect the people and
what that sort of policy turns into uh
recall you know through the
Telecommunications uh
watching everyone and looking over
everyone as Snowden uh revealed and I
wondered whether you saw that as
analogous to what's happened here with
the Russian disinformation uh that's the
original that's the 911 thing which has
then led to this sort of
idea that yes the policy we need to cut
this stuff out or whether that's part of
the same story whether whether whether
Patriot Act
um Stellar Wind inter
the Russian hoax is that is there a
lineage that these are all connected oh
for sure it's it's a single
unbroken chain from 9 11. the only other
piece I would add to it is this idea
from Peter turchin that we're dealing
with the overproduction of Elites we
have a lot of Highly Educated people
with nothing to do in our societies and
when the overproduction of Elites meets
the counter-terrorism world and they
succeed wildly in the war on terrorism
you have suddenly a bunch of people that
don't have anything to do
they start to sort of turn inward
um and then 2016 provides a kind of new
you know uh reason for existence well I
should actually add color to that
because it's more analogous than that
even because you had that's when Isis
started to make serious gains in Syria
as well as
um the uh movement in Ukraine uh the
name of which I've forgotten uh so where
those movements were using social uh
media uh so so this is actually very
similar I think to the 911 situation
very similar and in fact Isis came up a
bit in our research too one of the main
leaders uh though we've we're always
drawn to because she was one of the
smartest people in the room when there
was Aspen workshops and other venues
people talking about so-called Russian
disinfos this person Renee daresta the
former CIA fellow
her whole story which I always found
very suspicious was that she was just uh
an internet entrepreneur
and became concerned about anti-vaxxers
online but then the next thing you know
she's involved in battling Isis for the
White House it was a very uh rapid rise
to the top let's say from somebody who
claimed to be just a mere hobbyist so
for sure the battling of Isis
recruitment online was also one of the
uh predecessor activities to to the big
event in 2016 but actually you can go
further back than 9 11 and think this is
what Jacob Siegel does is he goes back
to uh um McCarthyism oh for sure yeah
what do you think about
um the global engagements the gec which
is the sort of Obama's agency
um the counter disinformation campaign
what are the leading uh groups of
disinformation that we should be focused
on
well that is definitely one of them the
global engagement center it's a it can
be overwhelming honestly Matt taibi and
his team created a list of 50 censorship
organizations these are both government
agencies but also government-funded
contractors think tanks groups like
Aspen Institute I worry you could very
quickly uh get into alphabet soup here
within with a huge number of
organizations but what I think is
important to remember too is that
there's something called the five eyes
Nations which at the heart of it is
really the United States and Britain
comes out of World War II where we do
joint surveillance together and it's
includes Canada Australia New Zealand as
well as as more Junior partners of it
but nonetheless as important to engage
in surveillance one of the aspects of
five eyes that we've always known about
is that Nations will spy on each other's
citizens to evade the restrictions of
not spying on each other's citizens so
one of the groups that has Target me
personally is a British organization
called The Institute for strategic
dialogue has been funded by the defense
department in the past has been funded
by the British government in the past
and is now out there claiming that I'm a
climate denier or a climate delayer both
of which are absolutely untrue well I've
not had that term climate delay well the
idea is that I'm suggesting that we
don't need to do something about climate
change anybody who knows my history over
the last 10 years knows that I'm one of
the most high profile Advocates of
nuclear power in the world have
advocated for building nuclear power
plants in Britain keeping them operating
the United States and building new ones
around the world so in part because of
climate change so the idea that I'm a
climate delayer is just disinformation
in their own language
um I just did a piece yesterday where I
pointed out that these people that want
to censor me and by the way the point of
writing a report attacking me as well as
Bjorn lombborg and Jordan Peterson as
climate deniers and climate delayers the
whole point of that is to de-platform me
and prevent organizations like the BBC
or the New York Times from interviewing
us or having us included that's fine
it's a college assassination it's a
conservative assassination it's very
specific as soon as I saw this report of
course I asked to interview the people
that wrote the report to have some sort
of conversation with them so they would
correct the record they have absolutely
refused and so what I've pointed out is
there's something quite pathological
about this you have the people that are
demanding that I be censored refuse to
stand in public conversation or even in
a podcast interview with me this is you
know at least in the Spanish Inquisition
you had a chance to respond to your
interrogator so there's something
pathological about this on the one hand
they're so arrogant as to think that
they should decide what the BBC and
other news media are allowed are allowed
to cover and what people should be
exposed to and then they're so insecure
and so small that they refuse to stand
for public debate with me so while we're
here in Britain I intend to go to their
offices and directly confront them and
demand that they have a meeting with me
because this kind of behavior is
unacceptable this is how you get to
totalitarianism you know people point
out well Michael you're still free to
have these conversations you're you have
a Twitter account and you're still out
there I am actively being censored on
Facebook at this very I wanted to ask
about that so how specifically is
Michael schellenberger being censored
right now I'll give you I'll give you
just I'll give you one recent example we
just broke the story of who the first
three
uh people who got sickened by covid were
they were three people working in the
Wuhan Institute of virology we have from
multiple sources within the US
government the names of these
individuals we broke the story with Matt
taibi as a joint project with racket in
public we've had incredible access to
whistleblowers and Witnesses because we
stood up to members of Congress who
berated us publicly and people trust
that we will protect our sources huge
story on Twitter it had been viewed
according to the the public count over 5
million times I shared it on Facebook
and five people total not five thousand
not five million five people total had
shared it with me with under a hundred
comments I mean it's an explosive story
and it was absolutely being censored and
suppressed on Facebook we know that I've
been I know that the moment I was
censored on Facebook because it happened
when my book apocalypse never came out
in 2020
similarly
the people that the the Facebook
Executives refused to meet or respond or
even acknowledge my existence during the
censorship the subcontractors that that
orchestrated the the hit on my
reputation refused to speak with me
it's it's really I it's not just wrong
and I I condemn it but there's something
quite pathological about this um our
societies the whole principle of free
speech is that even the even people who
are wrong
uh that the society is made better by
having the debate this is Voltaire I
mean this is uh you know I will defend
to the death your right to be wrong
publicly it's all the more frustrating
in your country and mine your country
obviously with the Second Amendment uh
sorry the First Amendment uh uh in the
Bill of Rights and in here you know this
is the country of John Mill writing
Ariel pagitica and in in the 17th
century this this these are the Nations
that should be bastions of free speech
we've somehow forgotten
that the significance and the importance
of it and it's it's shocking to me well
this this kind of gets at the knob of it
which is you know why is this going on
and we keep coming back to 2016 or the
rise of the internet but there is
something else here which is that there
is cancel culture cancel culture
precedes the censorship industrial
complex by many years
cancel culture is the idea that you
should not speak that your words create
harm we followed very closely the the
controversy here with Catherine Kathleen
stock in the attempt to prevent her from
speaking at Oxford the intervention by
your prime minister that she should be
allowed to speak her wonderful remarks
about the
the right to offend and the importance
of that I mean I find myself slightly
bewildered and disoriented by having to
make the case for free speech yeah
something that I I would have thought
would have been so basic or even sort of
cringe to have to speak out about Free
Speech because it just seems so obvious
I mean who would need to defend Free
Speech but here we are in a situation
where we have to tell young people in
particular that they are they should not
be protected from things that they find
offensive that being offended is part of
being alive
uh having negative emotions having
negative reactions feeling angry feeling
upset this is part of what it means to
be fully human and the idea that adults
or somebody should protect you from that
it's absolutely absurd and but what
we've seen that's so disturbing is the
tapping in to that extreme culture of
intolerance by the censorship industrial
complex so you can sort of see on the
top as an inorganic censorship
industrial complex
50 big organizations powerful
government-funded organizations at the
bottom is the support it is supported by
a lot of people absolutely and we see it
now attorney it's of it evolves it's
very adaptive so we see the censorship
industrial complex first they say we
have to worry about Russian
disinformation then they say we have to
worry about covid then they say we have
to censor dissident views on climate
change now what we're seeing and this is
the article today in unheard
as we see the United Nations we see
former president Barack Obama which
breaks my heart we see many world
leaders we see the European Union
claiming that there is some increase of
hatred in our societies and some
increase of hatred online look our
societies are more Western societies are
more tolerant of racial religious and
sexual minorities than they've ever been
I mean by orders of magnitude I mean
imagine your grandparents uh imagine how
homosexuality was dealt with in our
societies I one of my favorite
statistics is that in 1958 four percent
of Americans approved of the rights or
the approved of whites and blacks uh
being able to marry today it's over 96
percent who say that uh white and black
people should be allowed to marry the
level of Tolerance is incredible by any
historical or global standard and yet
here you have
prominent leaders suggesting that the
people are some somehow filled with
hatred and that the online environments
are somehow full of hatred I think it's
an absolute case of psychological
projection they're the ones who they
absolutely hate when you hear Hillary
Clinton saying they're deplorables yeah
when you see the this this condemnation
of ordinary people for expressing
genuine aspirations for self-government
we saw it here I mean we saw with brexit
right that anybody who sort of supported
brexit uh was somehow a racist somehow
intolerant I find it uh very troubling
it makes me very upset and angry because
I I think it you're calling somebody
you're totally misidentifying uh their
motivations and you're suggesting you're
finding the worst possible uh motivation
possible thing to say about somebody
um so we talked a little bit about the
UK and and you mentioned Kathleen stock
and so I actually uh Richardson has
appointed a free speech Czar which is
Arif Ahmed and so there is suggestion
that the current government under Rishi
do have an appreciation for free speech
at the same time there's the Online
safety bill which is going through
The House of the House of Lords at the
moment which is being debated which
would hand I as far as I've understood
it give power to the tech companies of
California to decide what can
can't be uh published which brings us to
the back right to the beginning of this
conversation
um and also what's happening now and I
believe some of your team are in Dublin
because there is the criminal justice
incitement to violence or hatred and
hate offenses Bill 2022 which is about
to go through which again is reducing
speech deemed hateful not just inciting
violence but zoomed hateful but then
what is hateful does it is does me
hating hate is that hateful right
where's the where's the where's the
bounds of that yeah what coming in from
American and City what's your what's
your opinion of these things that are
going on over here extremely disturbing
and all of it happening simultaneously
we've created a document that's
available to the public and people can
find it on our website at public where
we just document what's going on in all
these different countries it's very
scary so it's happening everywhere it's
happening in the EU it's happening in
Britain it's happening in Ireland Brazil
Canada United States in every country
there's a slightly different angle to to
it and we are still trying to figure out
exactly what the pattern is but it's
clearly coordinated we know it's
coordinated because we see things
happening simultaneously similar
justifications being used for censorship
similar cast of characters it's World
economic Forum it's Jacinda Arden from
New Zealand this uh the Christ Church
Massacre then led to a call for greater
censorship she then now is at Harvard
heading up their censorship Center we
see it Stanford yes she is Stanford just
announced a news they already had two
censorship organizations they just
announced a third one so we're seeing it
at think tanks we're seeing it in top
universities uh we're seeing that people
that in the revolving door out of these
intelligence and Military and security
organizations
so it's happening everywhere
Ireland is shocking I mean it would that
law would allow the police to go into
your home search your phones and
computers if they find so-called hateful
materials determine that you are guilty
until proven in this and guilty of a
plot to disseminate those materials
I mean Ireland I mean I mean people you
know Brits no Ireland Americans we love
going to Ireland I mean the friendliest
most tolerant people in the world I mean
what's this idea that somehow there's
been some eruption of hatred I mean
it's quite disturbing because and I I
will say though
I know it won't we have we can't we
can't leave it with us but I will say
the pushback is also working just simply
describing these efforts we you know we
for example that we we saw Obama claim
some big increase in hate I've noticed
that now the message there's been a few
claims that there's yes there's more
hate on online and we all get unheard
that there isn't we don't agree with
that well okay so here's a great moment
here the uh a BBC correspondent in the
United States uh secured an interview
with Elon Musk James Clayton James
Clayton sat down with Elon Musk uh to
put it mildly Mr Clayton was not
prepared for this interview he walks in
and he just repeats this claim that
anti-Semitism had increased on Twitter
since Elon Musk had taken it over where
did he get that claim from The Institute
for strategic dialogue in the very same
organization that's that's spreading
lies about me hmm he uh I I took me I
went as soon as he said it as soon as
this went viral I read the report it
took a matter of minutes for me to find
that they were classifying tweets
critical of George Soros in the world
economic Forum with no mention of
Judaism or jewishness or anything or
even of just tweets critical of George
Soros in the world economic Forum they
had classified as anti-semitic garbage
in garbage out is what we call that kind
of analysis but that's pervasive in
California
there's a California initiative to crack
down on hate online and they claim an
increase of hate incidents well you look
at the data in which you realize is that
they are not accounting for a reporting
bias meaning
that there's been an increase of reports
of hate online does that mean that
there's been an increase of hate online
well of course not you can easily
imagine that when you start tracking a
phenomenon the people tracking it get
better at detecting the phenomenon over
and over again in fact psychologists
have written a major research has been
done on this which is called concept
Creep meaning that we know
that what people consider harmful speech
or hateful speech is increasing so the
very same the we see it the reaction to
having Kathleen stock speak at Oxford
this demand from students that she be
censored we see that in the culture this
cancel culture this culture coinciding
with the intolerance from the rise of
social media the reinforcement of your
pre-existing beliefs so what we're
seeing is so this is yes it reinforces
us yeah we need more censorship look at
the hate that's going around this is
just it's just a cycle and it just
doubles everything down and the social
fear that's created you know my I've uh
uh people in my family who are Zoomers
in their early 20s when black lives
matter happened they felt incredible
pressure from their friends to put a
black Square on their Instagram why
don't you have a black furnish room why
don't you have a black lives matter sign
in your yard is that because you're a
racist I mean it was a Culture of Fear
this is a McCarthy's you know it's it's
The Crucible it's witch hunts it's it's
the attacks on uh on on Parker on
Parker on Julie J keen and this this
this fear that I will be accused
manifesting as me accusing others so the
accusation of
racism or transphobia the accusation of
that upon others as a defense mechanism
to protect myself from being accused
social media of course magnifying and
intensifying it
that's one thing and that's disturbing
you would want your
your leaders your cultural political
social leaders to push back against that
and say hey let's all calm down a bit
you know we're all more tolerant than
we've been in decades anybody who has
any historical memory will know that to
see them then taking advantage of it and
using it as a pretext for censorship is
very chilling very disturbing we need to
call it out in every instance and I will
say it does seem to work uh since our
efforts began on this and we started
calling out this Global effort to impose
what I think has to be called a kind of
totalitarianism a kind of censorship of
the kind that George Orwell warned
against I do think it's had an impact
and so what we've seen now is including
on the United Nations
their social media posts they start
talking about uh how there's a lot of
hate as opposed to making the claim of
an increase of hate because they knew
they don't have that it's still
disturbing for them to go around there
hate hate hate you know it's like who's
the hater here exactly yeah you know
what is the United Nations doing yeah an
organization where the Declaration of
Human Rights very explicitly protects
free speech and they're supposed to be
you know spreading brotherly love what
is the United Nations doing here yeah
spreading this idea that hatred is
rampant when there's no evidence for it
and demanding censorship
um so yeah I mean I do think it hasn't I
think the re the I I took great uh hope
from the prime minister's intervention
on the Kathleen yeah stock I think it
suggests that you know later today or
and over this week I'm looking forward
to interviewing ordinary britons on the
streets asking how would you feel if the
government were secretly reading your
direct messages because that's where
this is headed how would you commit sure
yeah but to do so legally I guess to
have some legal justification for it I
don't think Ordinary People want that we
saw with the Edward Stone oh I would
challenge you on that because the old me
would have been I've got nothing to hide
I'm happy with the government and what I
have changes I no longer trust the
government and and see how they act I
don't want them really because I don't
want them but yeah if we're fighting
terrorism or we're fighting whatever the
body is at the moment I'm happy to for
you to read my uh thing so I think most
people probably don't care that was a
tragedy of Snowden he was he said my
greatest worry is that I will sacrifice
my life for this and no one will care
and that's pretty much what happened no
very people give a damn I think in the
abstract I think that's true if I
haven't done anything wrong what I
should I be worried about but I think if
you ask people would you like to know if
if somebody taking an experimental drug
that's being prescribed for your
children is experiencing side effects
would you like to be informed about that
or would you rather that the government
just censor that information I think
most people would say yes I would like
to know I would like to know what the
consequences of experimental drugs are I
would not like to have a small number of
experts would you like the government to
decide whether you can hear a full range
of arguments for or against whether
Britain should be part of the European
Union I think most people would like to
see a broad range of arguments so but I
think it gets back to their the point
where we started with which is that we
find ourselves in a strange situation of
having to make the case for freedom of
speech I do think and I do think there
is a difference with surveillance which
is that I do think people after 911 in
particular accepted a fair amount of
surveillance of their Communications in
order to prevent a terror attack you
have many more cctvs in Britain you know
than we do in the United States there's
much more tolerance of that in Europe
than the United States and I think
there's uh you know there's some
justification for it and there's
certainly you can get we can get very
paranoid but I do think that when it
starts to get into censorship
and somebody else deciding what
information I should be allowed to read
and write I do think it goes too far and
I do think the public will be with us
but I do think it's also take some
effort and that's why we're here that's
why we're so we came to Britain is that
we felt that this was something that
needed to be a joint U.S UK effort we
see our governments cooperating in quite
negative ways and we felt like we needed
some sort of societal response to say
hey let's get back to kind of what
started this whole Western Civilization
thing in the first place which was that
Ordinary People should be allowed to
have voice
you know Winston I mean one of the
things I'm not a First Amendment expert
by any means I'm not a constitutional
scholar I don't know much about the
history but one thing that comes out
when you read the histories of the
period is there's always a question of
is Free Speech
sort of instrumental for democracy is it
something that you just sort of need to
have so people know how to vote the
right way in a democracy or so you can
have free markets or is it something
much more fundamental and something much
more what we call natural right Thomas
Jefferson in our Declaration of
Independence called an inalienable right
given by God not by
not by a piece of paper that's an
important Point by the way given by God
and I think that's part of the bigger
problem we're seeing is that God is
dying again and so we don't agree in
that so we don't have that underlying
concept to bind us all together but
maybe that's another conversation for
another podcast
absolutely but I will say atheists uh
have long been able to make a
justification for it as a natural rate
as something or even if you want to get
fully postmodern it's a rate that we
establish we articulate we we demand of
ourselves
but for me I find myself much more in
the latter Camp it's not just a means to
an end free speech for me it's like
eating or breathing I mean to be
deprived of it and it really helps to be
deprived of it to realize how precious
it is that this this this idea that we
should be able to express our own
thoughts and that we should have a right
to hear what other people think
it touches something much deeper in me
at least than just oh it's a way to have
a functioning democracy or a functioning
free markets it's about being human it's
why it's a fundamental human right
according to the United Nations
according to the American Constitution
and not just something that we allow you
to have because it makes things work
better I can sense you're trying to pull
this conversation together but you're I
don't want to be the next James Clinton
because you are a bit like musk and that
there's so many interesting things that
you're up to and you've done that uh
that I could easily miss them and
there's a couple of things I wanted to
do sure quickly ask you about if if time
permits uh
um firstly uh about Twitter I followed
the Twitter files closely anyone I think
who is skeptical or cynical about Legacy
Media which pretty much ignored the
whole thing uh was following it on
Twitter and we could see by the numbers
of people who were engaged on Twitter
that it was a big story
but being on the inside on the other
side of the curtain and and uh what was
the atmosphere like was it excitement
when you took pulled up to the the
Twitter HQ in San Francisco was just
like oh my God this is this is the or
were you like were you cynical about
that what what was it like it was
thrilling you know I mean you yeah we
got I mean so I came in through
berryways uh I did not know Elon Musk
and in fact I'm maybe the the person the
journalist who has been most critical of
Elon Musk for the supply chains to me
you have I am yeah and it had been for
10 years in fact I criticized Elon Musk
directly in Apocalypse never
and so about solar panels I remember
that about the solar panels and you may
know that the solar panels in China are
being made by uyghur Muslims who most of
whom are in concentration camps the
supply chains for lithium batteries is
very not mostly one to three million of
them but yeah sorry yeah exactly
um so yeah it's a very it's not great
you know the the supply chain for
producing oil and gas has high paid
workers many of them are unionized in
much more safe conditions uh people have
seen anyway I could go on about it but I
have criticized uh Elon Musk in the past
for that but
his taking over of Twitter was clearly
done for the right reasons people may
know that he massively overspent to buy
the company certainly could afford it
he's the world's richest man
the right reasons you mean not for money
clearly but rather it was mission driven
he was he's a free speech guy absolutely
wanted to say I don't want to suggest
that he's not I mean obviously he has
powerful business interests and and we
should be cautious around how those are
represented on the platform yeah that's
how dedicated to free speech has since
been yeah it's a little bit absolutely
and I've testified to Congress now on
this twice first time on the censorship
but the second time on big Tech and my
view just to get it out before we get
into uh Elon and Twitter a little bit
more is that the solution to this is is
transparent mandatory legally required
transparency by the social media
platforms
so Facebook and Twitter the First
Amendment
so one of the things is that it doesn't
allow it doesn't it it prevents you from
being forced to say certain things and
so you can't compel speech it's it's
that's another kind of censorship so
it's a so you can't compel Twitter and
Facebook to allow you to say certain
things but you could compel them to be
transparent about what kind of
censorship they're engaging in
um who's being censored but also who's
being de-platformed who's being
de-amplified meaning having their
content spread that should be open and I
think there should be a right to respond
so I should have a right to know how I'm
being censored by Facebook and I should
have a chance to respond that means I
can go on other social media platforms I
can criticize Facebook in fact I've done
this on other platforms and and try to
make my case elsewhere
um so I put that out there I think Elon
and Twitter should should be required to
have that level of radical transparency
I will say and of course I've or maybe
not of course but I've also said this to
Elon directly multiple times he that he
should be more transparent about the
decisions are being made and he has been
more transparent than the previous
owners he complied with the Turkish
government request to censor Turkish
journalists there's a legitimate debate
to be had about whether he should have
done that but when he because the
alternative was that Twitter would be
taken down completely in turkey that's
right and they had lost it they had
appealed many times in the courts in the
Turkish courts and lost and to his
credit he did publish on Twitter they
tweeted out the actual legal documents
and the names of the people that were
being censored that's a huge improvement
over what Twitter had done before and
certainly what Facebook was doing
but inside Twitter I mean you know Elon
himself is uh
a very intense personality I mean it's a
little bit I mean you know uh what you
see is what you get I think with Elon
he's a very intense personality
he's making jokes all the time you know
some of which are more successful than
others but certainly uh he's a major
Joker he loves to make jokes so his ship
posting isn't just reserved for Twitter
oh no he's no it's on edge Lord IRL as
well okay no I mean there were certainly
moments we're seeing there because we're
getting the files and we're like we
don't know how long we're gonna you know
you feel a little bit like you've just
uh it's like a smash and grab situation
you know you're trying to is that right
so you you comment you're at the
computers presumably you had an engineer
or something someone to help you I mean
I don't know how tech savvy you are and
and and you're kind of how did that work
what was what was the actual process
yeah we would put in these search
requests and of course but this at this
point there was three kind of well-known
journalists you know Barry Wise Man
taibi me but we also had our colleagues
with us so there's at times there was a
room of
you know seven or eight people plus the
Twitter staff making many many requests
them coming in uh with the files
um I saw no evidence that anybody had
gone through the files before they gave
them to us they were just doing these
searches and these were very large
document uh drops and so we were going
through you know thousands upon
thousands of emails and internal
messages
and it was yeah we're a sweaty
conference room you know uh did you you
didn't know what you were looking for
exactly we didn't know well we did in
the sense that we were there were there
were there had been events so for
example the 100 by laptop was a huge
decision and Matt TYB covered that
already by the time I came in I saw
things around it that I felt like I
needed to take a second crack at it so I
did a second round on the hunter by
laptop
um a month or a month after I think uh
Matt did
Barry Weiss looked at some of the key
people who had been de-amplified we
discovered that there were secret
blacklists they were actually called
that
called uh uh blacklisted basically
um for deamplification one of whom was
uh you know Jay bhattacharya who's a
very famous uh critic of covet
skepticism a professor at Stanford
we did the Trump do platforming this was
a major event so you have January 6th is
the famous Capital riot
January 7th there's a lot of internal
debate and really the decision is made
at that point really a decision to
de-platform Trump even though the
Twitter staff themselves had decided
that Trump's tweets had not violated
their terms of service and this was one
of the patterns of behavior is that
Twitter was just making up stuff as they
went along and to some extent that's
understandable that's what happens to
your new company but you hear they had a
terms of service that everybody agreed
to and they were just finding
justifications to kick Trump off the
platform and then the final decision was
made on January 8th and so when I got in
there Barry and Matt had decided to
split up January 6th 7th and 8th they
gave me what I think they thought was
the less important date which was
January 7th but sure enough it turned
out to be uh an important date because
it was where you could see the staff
trying to kind of invent justifications
to de-platform Trump
so those were some and then and then and
then at then the moment and really the
floor dropped out from under us is when
we started to see all of these
government officials FBI officials DHS
White House making demands on Twitter
and that was when
Matt started in particular because he
had had so much experience looking at
the military industrial complex he
started to look at the role of these
orchestrated campaigns like Hamilton 68
to basically
demean ordinary Twitter users as Russian
Bots
then it goes full circle again or goes
background again I should say because
you go to Congress for the hearing and
you are grilled and this is the people
elected to uphold free speech in America
are then grilling you for exposing
censorship of the government I guess the
government themselves trying to hide
their their dirty work
but you guys look like you're having fun
you and Matt well no no Barry wasn't
there you're kind of looking each other
giggling at this you know you were asked
if it was a some sort of threesome it
was it seemed farcical and amusing to
you well it was amusing to me in part
because they were going after Matt they
had already demonized me Democrats and
progressives had already demonized me in
2020 around apocalypse never where I say
climate change is real it's not the end
of the world we're going to solve it
with natural gas and nuclear power that
was already heretical and so they felt
like they'd already done their number on
me so they needed to focus their
attention on that type he's also a much
bigger personality as three times more
Twitter followers than I do
um very successful substack writer very
famous in the United States
and so they really focused all of their
energy on Matt
and when they kind of came to me the
famous moment in that hearing was that
the the member of Congress they kept
trying to kind of make it seem like
there was something wrong with us doing
the Twitter files like there was
something improper or maybe illegal
about it
the night before when a government
agency uh the the they had released the
members of Congress had released
documents showing that this Federal
Trade Commission which regulates Twitter
and other social media companies
had basically been demanding that Elon
Musk reveal who all the reporters were
who were involved in the Twitter files
as though we were doing something wrong
or illegal
and so one of the members of Congress
kind of clumsily was trying to figure
out my involvement and she said well
Elon invited you in I said no you know
it was actually Barry Weiss had invited
me and then she said
she said so then it was a threesome and
the whole room just erupted into
laughter because you have to remember
they're up on you know they're up above
you you know you feel like you're kind
of down and small you know looking up at
these members of Congress and they're
sort of accusing you and and DC is a
very unfunny place in many ways very
Square place and so but the room just
erupted into laughter
I knew enough
from uh having listened to comedians to
know that you should always let the
laughter die down before you respond and
I said
there was many more people involved than
that and that got another huge round of
of laughs and it was uh it was
and of course you know Barry Weiss is a
very famous lesbian she's maybe one of
the most famous lesbians in the United
States her wife is Nelly Bowles they
both worked at the New York Times and
when this went viral on Twitter Nelly
responded in all caps how many more
people were involved so you know it
really went on and on like that Elon was
delighted with it because he's a big
prankster and gangster and and so and
there had been some conflicts and
controversies and
but it felt like at that moment all all
was forgiven and I think it I think the
Democrats it was the Democrats because
one Republican I think who was properly
challenging those Democrats yeah
um but do you think the motivation of
those Democrats so going into that
firstly they're obviously completely
ill-prepared for they they didn't seem
to know the topic whatsoever but they
almost took you as the enemy so there
was no good faith
what's their motivation you think are
they trying to protect their colleagues
are they trying are they is it Trump
derangement Syndrome again is it
there's almost must Arrangement syndrome
yes in America they just assume oh he's
badly now is it that tribe but what what
do you think what the the energies at
play there in that uh I mean the sad
part of it is that the Democrat the
truth is they want more censorship they
want more censorship by online platforms
of disfavored views of what they
consider hate speech of the so-called
deplorables
I mean this is I I genuinely it is
genuinely sad because I was raised
Democrat I was very Progressive uh
radical left as a young man you know
when I graduated from high school the
Supreme Court
had a ruling that you could burn the
American flag Republicans were aghast
this the Democrats felt like it was a
victory for free speech
ACLU defended the right of neo-nazis to
March through a neighborhood of
Holocaust survivors in skogy Illinois
so the Democrats and liberals were the
party of free speech for most of my life
and that really starts to change with
the rise of cancel culture and wokeism
in the in the really the late in the
2010s or so and so the Democrats yeah
they want to see they want to see more
censorship is it an indication that they
have power you think because it's if
you're in power you're the one who wants
censorship if you're not in power yeah
you don't you want free speech so that's
right do you think it's just maybe a
simple black and white sort of scenario
I think it has to do with that I think I
mean look if you want to get really deep
in it I think wilkism is an effort to
create a new secular religion as a
substitute religion and so there's a
there's a fervency here there's a
dogmatism there's a
a kind of an intolerance of in a sense
that words are sort of magical and they
have a kind of magical spiritual power
to them there's all these taboos that
you're not you know you can't say that
trans women aren't real women that's a
taboo thing to say
you know it's taboo to suggest that you
could turn your that ISO you know it's
it's it's taboo for me to say
that I can't make myself a woman but I
could make myself a black man that's
totally taboo even though it's arguably
less ridiculous
there's taboo to say that climate change
isn't the end of the world these words
have a kind of uh there's so much
heaviness in the in the language
heaviness and inconsistencies yeah yeah
and so I think there's there's some of
that is just irrational I mean by all
accounts the Democrats lost that
Congressional hearing you know they're
here berating journalists accusing us of
not really being journalists uh that you
know the very moment that we were
testifying in front of Congress the IRS
sent an agent to Matt taibi's home
we know that the IRS investigation of
Advantage began the day Christmas Eve
day December 24th the day that he wrote
a Twitter files thread
describing CIA involvements in this in
Twitter files in the case against him
they actually the Irish case against
they sort of included some of his
written materials
so it's clear harassment wow so it's a
tax as well I mean it's it's taxes FBI
it's the intelligence Community it's big
government it's or it's it's and and
then also it's coming from a big swath
of the population it's it's an abuse of
power so this is the comp the censorship
industrial complex is indeed complex it
is it is complex it it involves a lot of
different and involves you know that we
it comes from Eisenhower's famous
warning about the military industrial
complex which was really a warning about
government contractors and Military
contractors having too much influence
over the decisions of members of
Congress or the executive branch so yeah
it's it's coming from all all sources I
mean I think that that was a very dark
moment in Congress to be to have those
attacks it had that levity in it but I
think the Democrats they just went too
far and so we saw many many on the left
on Twitter from very Progressive
Publications who themselves reacted to
this at the end of the day journalists
don't want to see other journalists
uh you know being persecuted in that way
I do think there were kind of some sense
of self-interest kicked in but I think
we're at the beginning of that I think
we need some serious engagement with the
public and and with members of Congress
to remind ourselves that you know these
the tables turn very quickly on this
kind of thing and you start going after
journalists the next thing you know you
know Republicans might be in power and
start abusing These Quiet these
institutions it seems like an obvious
point to make but obviously one that
needs to be made so Michael uh
this is just the beginning of you
explaining the censorship industrial
complex you're in London central or
Westminster this Thursday with Russell
Brown and Matt Toby uh two lefties who
again seem to be uh believe in the
importance of of maintaining Free Speech
uh and I'm sure they have a whole
Bunch extra to add to this as I've
already said several times complex issue
um what uh can you expect what's your
hope for that event and moving forward
in Practical terms well first Winston
we're grateful to you for all your
support in helping to pull it together
you've been an absolute Jewel to work
with and it's been a real pleasure
making friends with you over the last
several months it's been a great
pleasure and yeah I mean we want people
to show up
um and be there and participate for us
this this the the burden of protecting
freedom of speech can't rest on the
shoulders of Elon Musk as broad as those
shoulders are certainly can't rest on my
shoulders or Matt taibi or Russell Brand
we do need a proper Movement we are
starting to find each other I was very
happy to see that the British government
had also been engaged in surveillance of
Carolyn Lucas I guess the head of the
green party of Britain somebody with
whom I disagree on most issues certainly
nuclear and natural gas but I do think
that
there's an F there's a there's an
opportunity here for people that are
from
various political Persuasions to see
that Free Speech really should be a
common cause for the people so our hope
is that we'll have that event on
Thursday night we are gathering a
smaller group of free speech leaders on
Friday and the our aspiration is to have
a free speech Alliance to battle against
the axis of censorship which is
spreading its tentacles Across the
Western World and Beyond wonderful well
I wish you all the best of it thank you
for coming back to Marshall matters and
I hope the next episode maybe we can get
into UFO's
[Laughter]
proposing God indeed Michael
schellenberger thank you for speaking
with me today thanks for having me
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]